nowadays everyone's smoking everybody's  smoking everybody it's like the end  thing to do 100 and even like it's crazy  too because now you have active players  doing the weed [ __ ] like how you have  your strain oh is this it man that's the  um the packaging for it  oh that's fire the gelato yeah the  die-cut bag  the stereo milk  yo this will pop dude it is gonna pop in  L.A too yep see the bag's important that  die cut will stand out yeah  that's super fire  yeah good [ __ ] and you obviously you got  a quality test of wheat right first  Russian American Gangster right of  course  I stand by you  I'll stamp it um  my product like Pepsi you know what the  name is  hell yeah and you have a Pepsi here  not a Coke guy  very few people in this world are Pepsi  over Coke my dad's a Pepsi guy yeah yeah  Pepsi's like a coke bottle yes it's like  a [ __ ] underground rapper  it's like man I was listening to  Griselda before everybody